Just as we can talk about the degree of a
term, we can also talk about the degree of
an entire polynomial. The degree of a
polynomial is just equal to the highest
degree of any of its terms. So to figure
out the degree of a polynomial we first
need to figure out the degree of each of
its terms just like we did in the last
quiz. If we look back at one of the
polynomials we used earlier.
-12x^7+3x^2+64x, we can see that this is a
7th degree polynomial. We figure this out
by first calculating the degree of each
term, so this one is a seventh degree
term. This is a second degree term, and
this is a first degree term, because of
the invisible 1 next to this x that stands
on its own. The highest number out of 7, 2
and 1 is 7, so this is a 7th degree
polynomial.